Last week, we told you about a robot that could give you a tattoo.
This week, we're telling you about a tattoo that can give you a robot.
MIT and Microsoft revealed DuoSkin this past weekend,...
...a gold leaf temporary tattoo that wearers can interact with.
The circuits can be designed in standard image designing software...
...and then printed directly to cheap, temporary tattoo paper.
The video shows off four ways to use them:...
...as touch-sensitive input for tapping and sliding...
...that controls an object on a nearby display,...
...a thermochromic tattoo that changes color and design...
...if the wearers' body temperature rises,...
...a wireless communication device that can be paired with tech like NFC,...
...and a purely aesthetic tattoo jewelry necklace...
...with light-up LEDs embedded within.
The designs are beautiful but they're also inexpensive...
...and a 3x4 cm NFC tattoo costs less than $3.